in this lesson we're going to go through
10
negative number type problems we're
going to have addition subtraction
multiplication division
take this like you would take a little
quiz and we'll go over them and you can
see which ones you got right and which
ones you need to practice a little bit
more so if you need to
take a screenshot or pause the video see
if you can do these ten problems and
we'll dive right in
okay so the first problem negative seven
plus twelve did you get
positive five
okay just wanted to kind of go over this
so remember when you have seven negative
numbers you can think of that as like
walking backwards seven steps and then
plus 12 that's like you're adding 12 or
you're moving forward 12 steps so think
about relative to where you started are
you further forward or are you further
backwards from the starting point so
that's one way to think about it another
way to think about it is you can think
about earning money and spending money
so say for example if you earned 12
that's like a positive
and then you spent
seven dollars how much money do you have
well you have five dollars left so
you're still in the positive there you
still have some leftover money okay so
for number two we have nine minus 20.
now again you can use that same
technique you could think of you know
you're starting right here and then
you're walking forward nine steps and
then you're walking backwards 20 steps
and you say to yourself hmm relative to
where i started
am i further forward or am i further
backward well you can see you're going
to be further backwards from your
starting point and you can see that
you're going to be backwards 11 steps
that's one way to think about it another
way i like to think about it that can be
a little bit easier is to think of
whenever you see a subtraction problem
you see that minus sign
think of subtraction as
adding
the opposite so what you do i'll just do
that again is you
when you see that subtraction sign
change it to an addition sign but then
change that second number to the
opposite sign if it's positive you make
it negative if it's negative you make it
positive
then what you can do is you can kind of
think of this as like a like a little
scale or a little balance beam here you
can think of the negative numbers on one
side the positive numbers on the other
side and you're trying to balance now if
you had exactly
nine negatives and nine positives of
course it would balance out and they
would like cancel out and you'd end up
with zero
but in this case you can see that we
have more negative numbers than positive
numbers so you can see that the scale is
going to tilt towards the negative side
how many more negative numbers are there
than positive well you can see there's
more
negative numbers by 11 so it's a
negative 11. okay so for number three
now we've got a negative five plus a
negative eight did you get a negative 13
let's take a closer look at this one so
what you can think of here is like
you're walking backwards five steps
you're walking backwards another eight
steps in total you've walked backwards
thirteen steps a negative thirteen so
that's pretty easy so if you're adding
two negatives and numbers together you
just add the two numbers and it's going
to be a negative the ones that are a
little bit trickier like number two the
one we did just uh previously there is
you when one's positive one's negative
you have to see which one you have more
of when you're adding like that okay so
for number four negative seven minus a
negative thirteen
did you get six
well in this problem what i would do to
make it a little bit easier is again go
back to that technique we were talking
about earlier when you see a subtraction
sign
think of that subtraction sign as
changing it into an addition sign but
then make that second number there into
the opposite sign
so you can always change the subtraction
into adding the opposite now it's a
little bit easier because you know when
it's addition it's a little bit easier
you can think about hmm i've got 13
positives i got seven negatives i have
more positive numbers and negative
numbers how many more six more it's a
positive six or if you like that
technique i talked about with walking
forwards and backwards if you walk
backwards seven steps but then you walk
forward 13 steps
are you further ahead or further behind
from when you started
well you'd be further ahead because you
can see you're walking forward 13 steps
so a lot more forward than backwards
okay so for number five negative four
minus 8 did you get negative 12
well again on this problem what i would
do i would do the same thing we were
talking about in the last problem when
you subtract think of that as adding
the opposite so you change the
subtraction sign into an addition sign
you make that second number the opposite
sign
and now you can see we have a negative
plus a negative which is going to be a
negatives like walking backwards four
steps plus another eight steps and
totally walk backwards twelve steps so
for number 6 did you get 8 times
negative 4 is negative 32
now here we can see we're switching
gears in the first five problems we were
doing addition and subtraction in these
next few problems we're going to be
doing some multiplication and division
and the key thing to remember when
you're multiplying and dividing the
rules are the same so a negative times a
negative is a positive
a positive
times a positive is also a positive but
what's different is when you have one
negative and one positive or one
positive and one negative so the signs
are opposite then you're going to get a
negative result
so for number six you can see 8 times 4
is 32 but one of the numbers is positive
one's negative so we're ending up with a
negative number overall now if you want
to think about this a little bit more
intuitively you can say well let's see
if i spent four dollars so negative four
would be like four dollars that's going
out of your account
and imagine you did that eight times
maybe you bought some type of coffee or
something and you said okay i'm gonna
buy eight coffee so four dollars per
coffee times eight that's 32 dollars so
it's a negative 32 that you're spending
or it's going going out or away
okay for number seven did you get
negative 3 times negative 9 is positive
27
well here you can see we have a negative
times a negative
is a positive
so when you have an even number of
negatives you're going to get a positive
when you have an odd number of negatives
you're going to get a negative
and again you can see 3 times 9 is 27 a
negative times a negative is a positive
now if you want to think about this a
little bit from a different perspective
you could think of kind of like when you
use two negatives in a sentence like i'm
going to the store and then if you say
i'm not going to the store that not it's
like a negative word it negates okay
the fact that instead of going now
you're not going but if you said i'm not
not going
those two knots those two negatives are
undoing one another and
giving you a positive you actually are
going to the store so just a little bit
different way of looking at it but just
remember the rules here this is probably
the easiest way
for multiplying and dividing so
addition and subtraction you have to
keep separating your mind from
multiplying and dividing a little bit
different okay so for number eight 64
divided by negative eight
did you get
negative eight
now you can see we've got a positive
divided by a negative remember when you
see that fraction bar that's the same
thing as a negative as a division sign
there and a positive divided by a
negative does give us a negative
okay for number nine negative 144
divided by negative 12 did you get
positive 12.
again you can see 144 divided by 12 is
12. a negative divided by a negative
gives us a positive number so that's how
we're getting that one okay for number
10 negative 4
squared
now what's interesting about this
problem it does involve negative numbers
but we're adding in some exponents here
so you can see that we've got this
squared here
but remember what do you do first we
want to remember that pemdas you want to
remember that parentheses exponents
multiplication
division addition subtraction right so
the first thing we have to do here is
really to think about this exponent part
first 4 squared we know is 16
but then we're multiplying by this
negative here on the outside it's a
negative 16.
so you want to basically follow the
order of operations
and then
uh the multiplication comes after the
exponent so for number 10 you should be
getting negative 16. for number 11
negative 2 the quantity negative 2 i
should say to the fourth power so what
did you get for this one
should be positive 16
why positive 16 well you can think of
negative 2 to the fourth as actually
four negative twos
multiplied together and we know that
when we have an even number of negatives
we're going to get a positive when we're
multiplying the other way to do it is
you could do it step by step you could
say negative 2 times negative 2 is 4 and
then 4 times negative 2 is negative 8
and then negative 8 times negative 2 is
positive 16. but a shortcut is if you
can count up those the number of
negative numbers if it's an even amount
you're going to get a
positive and if you have an odd number
of negatives you're going to get a
negative and the key thing here on this
problem was that we really had
this whole quantity in parentheses the
negative 2. so it wasn't like number 10
where we had to do the exponents first
and then the multiplication here we took
the whole quantity the parentheses as a
group then the exponent second so great
job if you want to see more examples of
working with positive and negative
numbers and some more
reasoning by behind why it works go
ahead and check out the video that i
have for you here and if you want to
become a channel member and support this
channel you can join as a channel member
and i would greatly appreciate that as
well
i look forward to seeing you in the next
video